garbage.com it's your One-Stop shop for
Tony's goodies yeah baby we got a hot
set of fresh gear dropping Sunday April
30th at 7 p.m are you garbage.com the
link is in the description we're rolling
out the website we're rolling out the
store get it while supplies last
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out
they're good to be classy just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at Tony's in a new edition
she's upstairs taking a little siesta on
her new king-sized mattress Machi she's
saying that she wants to take a trip to
space okay score some moon rocks from
the neighborhood all right Mike co-host
is coming at you right next to me he is
the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman let me tell
you kids something the next time you're
reaching for a best pal do yourself a
favor make it a kitty give it up for KJ
Kevin James Ryan what's up gang thanks
sir thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you sign
up over there you get a bajillion hours
of content patent pending check it out
good time check it out gang we love you
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones Works to twos works the threes the
fours crosses the t's and dots the eyes
now you can get a little peek at them
ladies on that Toby cam give it up for
T-Bone mcgruffins it's Toby McDonald
everybody what up dude what's up bro yo
I gotta say we've had the addition for a
second now and it's nice to have a
little bit of classic
come around knows what he's talking
about first guy to use coasters in here
I don't even know he used a coaster and
I was like oh yeah we have coasters I've
been eating cereal off a plate in this
place gang the long hair ain't lying we
couldn't be more excited to have her
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today he has
family at this point he has an amazing
special out right now on his YouTube
page called sounds like Bruce and you
can check it out at Jay Larson comedy do
yourself a favor give it up for the one
the other Jay Larson everybody
[Laughter]
he goes show me around what are we doing
dude that's that's the part of me like
when I go to someone's house the first
thing I do is I go I'm like show me
around what do we got you want to tour
huh yeah yeah I want to know what's
going on I might settle into the kitchen
for a little bit because someone's like
maybe putting out a cheese plate so
they're doing the finishing touches and
then I'll be like show me around a
little bit what do you got I'm like what
do you got a pool let me see that pool
Contour you in your bathing suit now
when you take a little piece of cheese
and maybe a little slice of capicola and
walk around a lot of tour of course
you'll take it for a straw on a napkin
maybe on a napkin let's not get crazy
Marty's with neck what's a gentleman
like you do with your toothpicks on a
soiree like that here's what I'm right
in the trash you go in your pocket
because I put them in my pocket at a
wedding oh yeah oh I wake up it's like
I've been making martinis dude if I pass
out I stab myself in the leg the best
part of you asking that question is I
could see your brain being like first
thought was like whoa mine go
immediately into my pocket if the trash
was right next to you put it in the
pocket he's like I might need it later
to pick up some chicken little gabagoola
there yeah no I'll yeah I'll throw it
I'll put it in the napkin and then uh
but I'll tell you this like when people
come by with Paso hors d'oeuvres I don't
take a napkin I just go just give me the
head yeah I don't need to mess around
okay how greasy is this thing you know
they want you to take a napkin I'm like
no I'm good are you a little plate guy
like a little plate I mean they're all
dogging will you pick around the the the
hors d'oeuvres or will you make yourself
a little plate and then go sit something
yeah I'll take a little plate like that
but if it's past hors d'oeuvres uh-huh
I'm going solo boom popular so you gotta
do it keep an eye for my faves you know
what I mean when you see them I'm like
all right make our way over there have
you ever posted by the door they come
have you ever located
the line of egress out of the kitchen
no yeah me either totally you think I
think there's a limited Supply when
you're at those things you're like all
right you've got to keep an eye on the
time there are for the good stuff there
is a limited Supply you can have all the
Southwest egg rolls you want but the
bacon wrapped scallops they got like six
of them who's catering this Cheesecake
Factory what event I wish because I
could be so lucky that's off the menu of
our buddy's wedding this fall you would
be right at home with a plate of Olives
talking about some chairs just like oh
where'd you get these chairs yes of
course I was just at someone's house
here damn like you like the mid-century
mod huh
this looks
not a frogman it's nice
I like it yeah you do have uh
up justice your classy guy man you
really are I'm not that classic I just
like you're refined I'll give you that
you're polished yeah we've talked about
this my mom was like that's my mom like
not like she went to finishing school or
anything because she didn't have any
money like my neighbor used to say guys
like your mom dude champagne taste on
the beer budget yeah that's my mom to a
T and it's like so when I can when I see
something nice you know what I mean I'll
get it but the the trash in me will be
like uh something that's like worn down
it's a nice rug but it's worn down I'm
like well that's where I'm at you know
what I mean and then I look and I'm like
I can't wait to graduate to having the
brand new or a mint oriental rug and
then this one can go in the garage and
the kids playroom you know what I mean
there you go uh you're good with that
too I wanted to uh before I was saying I
wanted to ask you about that you're not
only a classy guy you're educating the
next generation of larsons to be classy
oh yeah you do it right with the kids
even if it's something as simple as
making s'mores you got it all laid out
on the pitch picnic table the fire's
going perfect I mean you got a code yeah
your Instagram stories are the childhood
I wanted man well that's exactly really
I give them I I you wanted I gave him
what I wanted you know what I mean so
like they have those crazy Playhouse in
my garage and it's got a piano for my
daughter drum set for my son I seen it
ouch you know what I mean every game you
could want every craft you could want
Lego table zip line like you name it I
got it and I do talk to kids sometimes
like they're little adults you know what
I mean I want them to like take these
things on and just like because we
sometimes as your Roth IRA doing huh
that's you got money for retirement got
money in the market I have told them
like listen we're going to learn about
money when you make a dollar You're
Gonna Save 50 cents like that's what
you're gonna do like is that how you do
it get it in I gotta I mean dude we got
no financial planning as kids you know I
have no you should be I got advising me
dude
I haven't paid taxes yet trust me I'm
not looking at like
50 cents every week and I invested for
you guys in my own account my kids are
doing great you guys I don't know
do they have little little accounts and
they have a little savings no we have
little like I have a coffee tin and a
T-10 and they each have one and we put
cash in there but like good stuff like
we go to the flower market in downtown
L.A I'd take 40 out of each we spend 80m
flowers come home make bouquets set up a
flower stand we went through a cost like
this is what we paid this is what we
profit each kid made their money back
plus 32 bucks come on wait a minute
instead of a lemonade stand you're doing
flower shop
I was moving uh I was moving water down
Crystal Light when I was a kid step on
his own Supply stepped on iced tea dude
so was I that should be a garbage
question did you have powdered iced tea
as a kid
yeah yeah of course I'd always put a
little whack when I got it in the glass
too get a little extra juice a little
bump he's doing the rim
[Laughter]
you're a big life bit guy we bumped
India down at uh Austin and I don't know
did you did you see us in line did you
know we were in line so I didn't because
I I left my phone at the counter I'm all
flustered I'm traveling have a couple in
me now get it and and I was at I left my
phone on the rental car yeah counter and
I step away I go to get the keys I'm
walking and then the guy goes Sarah your
phone and I turn around oh my gosh [__]
I'm an idiot and then he goes yeah he's
probably he's not paying attention he's
probably on his phone or something like
that and I'm like this [__] jerk off
who's coming at me I was like what guy
in line is this aggravate I turn around
it's all [__] Jay Larson yeah no I
didn't see you you just said once you
know I'm you know come here we're
listening to everything we're watching
everything and so I as soon as I hear
that I'm like oh who's this guy like
what is this is there something
happening who's the idiot and then I see
it's you and I'm like hey what are we
doing here guys
the [__] Austin Airport I mean that's
like my favorite thing to do is I sharp
at people all the time all the time and
it either goes well or doesn't go well
dude you're yelling at people fun way
like that like make jokes like the other
day I'm sitting down right where was I
I'm sitting down the guy a [__] I'm
sitting at this coffee shop and they're
these like I like high school or college
girls right and there's three of them
and they're like what should we get and
two are back here and one's up front the
one up front has glasses she goes you
guys know I'm legally blind and then she
turns back and I lean over I go how many
times we're gonna hear that huh
cause you know she said
he didn't hear me the two friends did
and they lost it and I was like gonna be
a good day yeah there we go got one
under my belt that's gee you like life
you're doing you're having fun that's
all like somebody is dude I'm out there
I live life I go to the nines you never
know what's gonna happen that's what
sounds like Bruce is it sounds like
Bruce sounds one of my favorite all-time
bits all-time bits man [__]
unbelievable congratulations on the
special thank you buddy thank you
[__] awesome you know uh we love you
you're one of our absolute favorites
glad you're here man I I wish I could
say the same
no you know how I feel about you of
course baby of course you're also a
refined man we were we were both in
Austin at the same time and we were
texting back trying to get the board
standard what's this what's your
schedule and they finally calls me what
are we doing texting back and forth I go
that's a gentleman yeah
where's a nice meal for you but he goes
I'm gonna have a cocktail on a roof by
myself get my head on straight go yeah I
go that's a confident refined man and
you know what I went up to the roof deck
and it wasn't what I wanted and I they
go would you like I go can I sit the bar
they go we can't just sit at the bar and
I'm like oh just tables and they go yeah
and I go can I take a look they go sure
I take a look I go I think I'll be all
right downstairs went downstairs to the
bar downstairs sat there they went out
by the pool and hung up by the pool
chatted up with a couple people you know
what I mean there's a couple sitting
there I chirp a little yeah because
people go there to watch the bats you
know the bats come up from the bridge
it's right at our hotel yeah and I go
what are we doing here we're watching
for the bats and they go yeah what time
does this do I don't have all night what
are we doing here and they're all sudden
in my plan they're like we don't who is
this guy yeah yeah yeah it's my favorite
thing well you guys want to get out of
here and get dinner you guys swinging
what's happening will you chat somebody
up at the air you're probably good at an
airport bar I feel a little bit I mean
I'll do it some places I just want to
like settle down and get away from
people you know what I mean but I did at
the airport bar I saw this moment I end
up sitting next to her and she I go what
do you got over there you're going with
the chiquitos really yeah and she's like
yeah she goes you want to try him I go
no we she ends up what she said what do
you want to try them she's an influencer
from Australia don't take my clothes off
um
I would have yeah I've tried people's
food before really I didn't but uh we
end up chatting for a while if I offered
you something would you try it no I said
people I didn't say [__] I'd say
first of all what are you gonna offer up
hey you want the toothpicks in my pocket
no you would be fun to go to a
restaurant and be like let's just order
a bunch of stuff because you know he's
like yeah [__] well let's do it yeah
I love a bunch of stuff yeah he's a big
bunch of stuff yeah
I don't think that it should be one
entree it shouldn't be specific oh no
way really no it should be a bunch of
different things that everybody like a
family meal
but at a restaurant does that make sense
no one else is there but you everybody
gets a plate you get the pasta you get
the steak you get the chicken you get
the and then you make a little make a
little plate for yourself we know what
you're talking about do you like Tapas
do you enjoy Toppers I love topics I
love topics small plates you kidding me
small plates oh shrimps and green sauce
let's go what are you doing
that's what they have I know I like it
do you cook I cook I do a little cooking
all right Bird does a little cooking my
girl she cooks nice yeah sausage and
peppers I feel like that's something you
have them down
sausage
I'm good at reheating spaghetti
yeah
take that put that in your pipe and bite
that I have it tricked out
oh let me guess you pour a little water
in the Bowl before you put in the
microwave what what trick are you gonna
look at that sounds pretty good who
you've been talking too much
now I say this all the time my my great
aunt uh or my aunt used to do it all the
time my Aunt Mary Catherine she would
take it she would take the leftover
spaghetti put it in a cast iron skillet
slice it up so it's it's real small and
then add a little water it gets real
real creamy then you put a little
parmesan cheese on it
so it's it's like turns into like a
risotto
spaghetti risotto yeah that's how they
were selling it over at Holy House holy
[__] risotto tonight kids ah we didn't
know what risotto was in my house now
Rice-A-Roni that was the closest to
risotto we ever got what was the food
growing up was your mom a cook no no no
single mom yeah my Nana was the cook so
like you come home and there'd be
Staples some nights would be beef stew
some nights it'd be spaghetti meatballs
some nights it would be pork chops baked
you know what she would do too she cut a
tomato in half whoa
[__] groundbreaking over there
yeah guys I I saw it happen
I wouldn't believe it I didn't see it I
heard stories Nana was Julia Child and
then breadcrumbs and then bake them
baked tomatoes with breadcrumb is just
like a little bit of butter on there
probably I don't know so like all right
she would do she was half Irish half
Italian so you were getting something
like that you know what I mean I was
just telling someone another pot her
go-to move was if like the sauce was
boiling or the gravy she'd call it and
you were hungry she'd take a piece of
bread and just dip it put it on a plate
with a fork and it was just like if I
ever have a restaurant that would be a
nap
a lot of those Italian dishes the like
the old school peasant ones they have
like chunks of bread in them yeah like
in like a sauce because they didn't have
cheese or whatever so they put the bread
in there well yeah that's a great hack
if you don't have if you don't have
parmesan at home you just get some bread
crumbs you toast them in olive oil and
you use that and it tastes like a it's
like a little subsy man Stanley Tucci
taught me that no he didn't hey he came
over last week
I would love Stanley Tucci on this show
oh man
someone make that happen Class Act
that guy if he doesn't live here he's
got a place spend time here yeah
damn it's got a couple of bucks bro I
got a couple of spots around that's what
I mean place in Italy what if he was
sitting he goes what are those runs are
those the 88s
oh man you have no they can't order in
the candy for this big man has a very
particular about the candy I'll be
honest the fact that there's no
chocolate over there is a big letdown
who has the chocolate in the nobody puts
chocolate in those things volcano does
damn he's got one peanut M M's and runs
uh all right side to side you want sweet
who's going with the baseball Gumball
who needs a prize what are the prize and
they get like a little parachute guy you
throw up in the air one time there's
ninja swing out the budget for the
parachute we could get the guy no
battery they're a little ninjas okay
yeah little ninjas and the baseball
comes iconic you didn't have that when
you were a kid playing little league
yeah what do you mean yeah I mean I
remember them nobody wants them he said
I passed over them for the peanut M M's
when you leave it's gonna be full of
gold you believe in this piece of [__]
talking trash
I'm gonna get one on the way out
hey you better have a recorder on you
buddy yeah go hit the coffee can all
right
there's no free rides here at Tony's
who's caring no I know who's carrying
change anyway true I got the key don't
worry
I haven't hidden though so we'll have to
wait it's in a safe deposit box it's in
my pocket it's in a tin in the kitchen
that says key to the gum balls not key
to the gumball yeah definitely not the
key to the gumball have you ever in a
pinch light on Cash ever dipped into one
of the savings accounts for your kids
yes yeah oh yeah going to get bread or
something I've been there with them what
is this the 50s I gotta go get bread we
gotta survive the winner don't take
credit cash only my kids have seen me
like like if I like uh I've had like
someone come by and do like a yard
cleanup or just someone that's gonna
take cash yeah and so I go in there like
hey I go I'll put it back and they're
like dead you better not go first of all
I put it here in the first place yeah
and Banks loan money out that's what we
do yeah and then they're like all right
do I get my 12 percent yeah
is there so many I was curious about
that is somebody cutting the lawn or are
you doing that yourself so I just
cleaned off the all the roofs you know
what I mean okay because it's crazy
like a blower or something well it was
just so much rain in La I had to rake it
all down because there's crazy pine
trees in my neighborhood so when I say I
have foot traffic people specifically
walk my street because those trees are
so beautiful it's non-stop by my house
okay so I cleaned all that off and then
I went to my landlord I'm like hey man
I'm gonna get someone to come do like
just an overall cleanup there's been so
much water and uh he was like yeah okay
and now I just hired the guy full time
you know what I mean not full these out
there every day Mr Lawson you need a
sandwich he's weekly you know what I
mean he comes weekly he'll be there on
Friday what's up what's up Luis if
you're out there listening
I mean there's no one you know I I don't
have grass to mow sure that was my
favorite thing as a kid you know I had
to sit down mower we had an acre in the
back bro that ain't bad what kind of
mower are you bumping with a surf
surf listen to me it came with the house
I think I've told you guys on the
podcast I came with the house wait
s-e-r-f-s-e-r-f you're not gonna it's
there I don't think they made anymore it
was old when we got it it's dude Google
isn't even Auto auto doing this
no one of these maybe it was no simply
surf that that's it yeah that's old
school man old school that's like 50s
that runs on diesel yeah I mean I
remember like running out of gas and
having go to the gas that was my job I
like started mowing the lawn when I was
like same here yeah yeah I loved it and
then my friends would come over and like
we're doing like a monologue like what
are you gonna be done I'm like oh like
three hours yeah okay let's talk about
that liquid IV baby liquid eye vessels
staple and I mean Staple in the Foley
household thanks to the generosity of
liquid IV good peeps got all kinds of
varieties listen let me tell you
something I'm a fat piece of [__] I'm
trying to work out that powers me
through my workout and it's tailgating
season coming up you're gonna be out
you're going to be crushing hot dogs
you're going to be down in booze you're
going to be out in a hot parking lot
you're going to pass out you're going to
fall out get the electrolytes up with a
delicious tasting liquid ID I like the
tropical punch yeah that's yeah uh
liquid Ivy has you covered in just one
stick you get five essential vitamins
and two times faster hydration than just
water alone it feels like my magic power
when I I'm hungover got a split in a
headache chug a bottle of that maybe a
shot or through a dream oh good night
slice of Sams and you're in business uh
you need to feed you got the vitamins
you need to feel your best B3 B5 B6 B12
and vitamin C it's also non-GMO
gluten-free dairy free and soy free baby
so here's what we're doing grab your
liquid IV in bulk nationwide at Costco
or you can get 20 off when you go to
liquid iv.com use the code garbage to
check out that's 20 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using Code promo code garbage at
liquid iv.com do it okay let's talk
about Factor back
spring is here spring is sprung Summer's
around the corner it's gonna be swimsuit
season pretty soon got to tighten up
we're a big factor people uh-huh my only
problem is I like them so much that I
all that I eat too but you gotta stick
to one they're delicious they're
fantastic number one ready to eat meal
kit delivers nutritious meals straight
to your door leaving you more time to go
outside soak up the sun have a good time
go to a concert smoke a little doobie
whatever you want to do fantastic we
love them yeah I'm a big fan like I said
I order uh I order a handful of them a
week now just because we're on the run
and everything and you can go and you
order exactly what you like and it just
takes the thought out if I'm leaving the
studio and I want to stop and get a
slice of pizza I go no you know what I
gotta Factor at home I'll be eating in
four minutes
throwing a Diet Coke and air for the
cherry on top you do them I throw them
in a skillet the toss them in a bowl
shout out to the shredded taco bowl what
are we doing you can pop in the
microwave two minutes and they're ready
to go you can eat it right out of the
container over 34 Chef prepared
dietitian approved each week there's
something new and exciting to try
Factory meals come in a variety of
Lifestyle options so if you're vegan
vegetarian keto or Gallery gown there's
something delicious delicious waiting
for you head to factormeals.com
garbage50 and use code garbage50 to get
50 off here wait a minute they're giving
it away that's garbage that's code
garbage 50 at factormeals.com garbage50
to get 50 off your first box do it baby
try them gang I hate it on it there'd be
like a party in the summer though yeah
and everyone's like we're all going to
Steve's the pool's open and I'm like I
gotta get back at least cut the front
yard I would do half at a time yeah yeah
I would lie it's too wet I can't cut it
Mom I can't cut it I would go to my
Nana's and my aunts and mow their lawns
too in reading but my aunt Rue was a
little bougie and she'd only let me cut
the back she'd had someone come and do
the first bro come to the front she
wouldn't let me touch the front of me
would you ride the mower over there no
it's like three and a half miles okay go
around you gotta needs they have an easy
then pop in the house talk with her for
a little bit Jason and then I would go
next door do the back seat Auntie Rue
Auntie Gert you were probably you were
probably a kid that other parents loved
that well yeah you're you're you're
you're uh you're a parent Whisperer
you're an older soul I am an older soul
and I didn't have a dad so other dads
were like [__] rad with me they're
like I'd show up at the house I'm like
what are you cleaning the gutters out of
them again we just knocked him out you
know
good kids like you big job I would cross
it like parents did love me but there
was I mean I had buddies parents like
like my buddies my buddy Phil goddesses
mom's Soul Barbara I call her Babs and
she she hated me I like Babs she's like
I don't because you by the way my kids
they call every one of their friends
parents by their first name that's all
that's wild there is no Mr Larson
there's no mystery so they call you Jay
Jay dude hey Jay can I have some more
milk no kids eating milk
[Laughter]
I do mess with them and go it's Mr
Larson they're like okay Jay all right
they hey Jay's acting up again dude I
chaperoned my daughters she slammed the
door on your face like a month ago and
so with them like we get back to school
we walk into the classroom and I'm like
I'm gonna go peek in my son's classroom
you know I mean there's something that
would never happen when I was a kid but
I'm just like I'm an active parent you
know what I mean so I go to his room and
I like peek in the door and like three
everyone sees me except my son's in the
clouds constantly three kids are like
Jay Jay my son is just sitting there and
then I see his teacher I go hey I was
just gonna say hi to Reed and she goes
oh yeah and then he sees me he's like
good and then runs gives me a hug and
he's like can I go home with you right
now and I was like no go back to class
kid's a go-getter I like it
he's got his heads in the class in a
media looking for early dismissal he's
trying to get out of there get out of
here any his crew or any any of your
daughter's crew that rubs you the wrong
way or anything like that yeah there's a
couple kids there's a couple kids I've
given a little elbow when they're
looking I didn't know if you were gonna
answer that
no there's just a couple kids that
you're just like Jesus is this bad like
what are your parents doing home stop
you know like a couple kids I've had to
just like and I just treat them like my
kids I go hey man I don't talk to
friends like that so I'm just going to
take a time out and not talk to you for
a little bit all right are you saying
that to the kid yeah well a kid called
me fat bro you think I'm gonna hang with
that kid no you gotta learn your lesson
learn some respect I want to hang with
that kid because you're hanging with
these kids they're like at your house
they're sleeping over what context did
he call you fat well let's be honest the
kid's on the Spectrum okay and he just
he was just like I was like yeah we got
to get going and goes oh yeah and he
goes I honestly forget he just goes well
you're fat anyway and I go what and then
and then I end up I end up then I had to
have a talk with the dad and I go hey
man can I ask you a question he goes
yeah I go are you like saying fat around
the house around the kids and like
putting this in their head and he goes
waggle you know he called me fat he's
like what and they do they're very like
they're very I think they're very health
conscious and I think sometimes that can
like rub to the kids and they're gonna
like all of a sudden yeah you know they
count calories they're the ones who
taught my kids calories in the back of a
bag why does a six-year-old need to know
what calories are like doesn't make any
sense to me that's just me you know what
I mean everyone in my house overeats and
I just see this stuff and I'm like get
this away from my kids yeah counting
calories as a kid is a little wacky it's
crazy yeah it's crazy just look at it
you can't go and your your boy's kind of
a dick dude yeah a friend of yours yeah
crazy is this guy a child or is this
guy's deal I will tell you this you want
class at they just had a fitness
challenge and I went over and like you
know chaperone Parts yeah okay and I'm
leaving and my son uh after his each
class at a different time his in the
afternoon so after that I'm like we walk
back and he's like all that everyone in
those two grades the third grade they're
all getting their snacks to come out eat
at the table and I go all right buddy
I'll see you and he goes hold on hold on
I go away because I want to introduce
you to a couple of my friends and he's
like Jimmy's my dad and I go hey Jim
like couple kids I haven't met yet and
I'm like hey Jimmy I heard a lot about
you and then he goes Dad this is
Jonathan over here and then I go all
right I gotta go because hold on hold on
Nico's in the other class let me get him
and I was just like who is this kid
introducing me to his boys
is my dad he's a good [__] he's all
right he's a good guy he's one of us you
know what I mean he's gonna show you
it's totally cool yeah a couple of
people you got to meet he's a friend of
ours what do you want first and then the
three of them come on like can you get
us out of here
I am your fact what it's a deal
I thought you were gonna you pulled it
down aside hey man you called me fat all
right he's here tonight
that Jay Larson's a fat ass that's what
the dad's saying what up also I don't
know if we ever talk to you speaking of
Babs do you have anybody in your family
or immediate circle that doesn't you
don't use the first names like you're a
big nickname guy yeah right like you
recall you're a kid calling your you
know hey Babs anybody anything floating
around everybody I do the same thing I
remember my ex used to be like you can't
give people a nickname the second you
meet them like if someone said they're
like if someone goes oh this is my wife
Michelle I'd be like Mish what's up like
I would go right to it
um but let me think like no everyone in
my family there are no nicknames really
no one has a nickname and everyone is
just goes by their first name everybody
I always wanted a nickname I never got
one as a kid yeah
I don't have I got one late I had a lot
of yeah as a kid a lot of shitty ones
but nothing ever nothing ever suck you
know what I mean like you know so now I
have Kippy from Keith Robinson that's
stuck the second everybody heard that
they're like that's yeah that's like 10
years more aunts and uncles Babs is a
real good one I have a grandma Babs
really we're going over to Grandma and
Babs
uh
uh I don't think her Teresa was her
first name I don't wear baths it was
Michelle I think her middle name was
Barbara but Barbara for Babs is perfect
yeah yeah a Babs is a is a Babs is a fun
mom she doesn't like it you don't you
don't cross back no you you you you're a
waitress at a diner when you're baps
yeah and if you don't have that energy
somewhere you know what I mean yeah you
have to have it to get up yeah sure it's
like that secretary in that in that uh
in that Gary gallman joke about the
abbreviation of the states
we appreciate that [__] that's a bit
you probably love Yeah
nuances specificity in creating The
Omelette bar was real good oh God The
Omelette bar had just been Advanced and
he gets so subtle into that he goes you
gotta understand it was sweeping the
Nations
shout out to the goal gang the new
special
sounds like Bruce on YouTube right now
we got Jay Larson in in in in in Toadies
here yep do a little patreon cues yes
guys so when you joined uh patreon we'll
answer your garbage question on the air
it's just the best way to do it patreon
gets to First crank in it so sign up
gang it's a party over there uh this
one's from Michael
have you heard anyone you know and ever
submitted an application to Survivor
no I will I will though are you ready
because yeah reality TV was big back in
the day in Hollywood I was never into
reality TV okay but my friend got
approached by producers of The Amazing
Race ah and he came to me goes would you
want to do this and I was like did I
want to be on a reality show I'm trying
to like this I this was like 2001. yeah
and I'm like I want to be an actor I
want to be a writer I'm like that's why
would I ever go do some stupid reality
show and then we just like sat around
when I drink and we're like how great
would it be his grandparents to be able
to tell our grandkids me and my buddy
raced around the world for a million
bucks and we're like all right let's do
it so we go in for the interview we're
going for the interview and there's like
we did a submission tape of the two of
us playing panel tennis in this back and
forth was really fun and uh we they like
all right got to the next stage yeah we
got to producers so they go to a hotel
they check into a room then you go to
this conference room there's 12
producers we go in and we're like hey
what's up guys and they're like hey and
they're like so what do you think about
the show and they're like well to be
honest none of us ever watched it and
they go you've never seen the show and
we're like nope but we're here we hear
great things you guys are doing a great
job out there and they go what make why
would you think you could win this show
if you've never seen it we're like well
that's what we think our cachet is like
we're the two that have never even seen
the show we go into it blind and then
like the producer that like found us was
like you guys are tanking right now
really like we're gonna send a VCR to
your room go watch some episodes come
back in two hours we're like I feel like
it would have been like endearing I'm
like hey we've never
that's why we'd be so good yeah and so
we go back we watch a couple apps we
come back two hours later as we walk in
we're like guys huge fans of the show
and uh they didn't pick us and which I'm
glad at the end I mean it would have
been cool but that's a lot though yeah
because there's a lot of comedians that
have been on reality shows you know what
I mean the Obama was on a reality show
Schumer was on a reality show yeah yeah
I mean actually pajitzki and Theo both
were in reality shows before they were
he was on the real Road Rules I think
yeah I think they were both on it
together maybe I think yeah they might
have crossed over something so you can
still like go for what you want and
starting there you know yeah of course
yeah we're doing studio audience what do
you mean a member of a studio audience
no never I did crowd warm-up though
there you go how'd you do you were
probably either good or really bad it
was either way or you dang I hit both
ends of the spectrum I would crush and
then I got fired because I thought it'd
be funny we do it was like The Newlywed
Game redone and after this horrible
there was this like a tank question and
answer and I come out and I'm like
ladies and gentlemen congratulations you
just witnessed the worst question in the
history of the Newlywed Game and the
head of the studio was there and goes
who the [__] is this [__] fired the
next day yeah you're too real yeah
they're cute yeah that's not helping
anyone here
hey guys this show sucks uh anyway where
are you from man
they got Tulsa in the house you want a
Tootsie Roll what do you want you would
have been on The Amazing Race going guys
why are we rushing I mean we're on
vacation yeah it's relaxed what are we
doing here guys our legs a little bit I
got Tapas coming here who gives you [__]
come on we're in Seville
I mean how many times a year are you in
Toledo you know what I mean you go into
it knowing full well that you guys are
going to come in last you're going to
take your time and enjoy the vacation
yeah on their dime
I don't know how that works but if they
had to wait for everyone to cross the
finish line oh yeah just I'll wait and
they're like God damn it we're gonna
just Chase still in the south of France
for some reason you're finishing up an
espresso I'm gonna finish this up I'll
be right over
Mr Watson you souffle is ready they
fined me I've changed my identity I have
a new job
yeah you can appreciate yourself
oh God that's too [__] funny have you
guys ever applied for any of those
things
uh no I don't think so
um I think you'd know yeah not that I
know I was I was thinking studio
audience I did a studio audience once uh
because a friend was on a show we just
went to have like a group of comics went
to hang out but a big thing in New York
is a lot of people a lot of comics would
pay their bills by doing the Jerry
Springer Show because it was shot in
Connecticut oh my God you get on a bus
in Times Square they pick up just like
yeah it look like a chain gang dude
they give you a hamster talking about
the lowest of the low yeah it's the ham
sandwich in a baggie yeah it was a ham
sandwich I learned a Dunes cookies and
you'd have to do like four episodes
they'd go how much do they pay you like
38 bucks a day it was like bad yeah yeah
why in Connecticut that's where the
students should I shoot it yeah no I get
that but I feel like you cut down an
expenses just do it in Times Square sure
yeah I don't know I don't know man
probably cheaper uh Studios up there uh
but we had a buddy that did it and got
bed bugs on the bus oh my god when
you're getting a specific type of
disease or bugs that's not even in that
location on a bus yeah who's getting bed
bugs on a bus
catching shingles oh man I I did an open
casting call for uh for a frozen mac and
cheese one time where I had to sit in
front of the pizza I can't even I can't
even do it they didn't pick me it was
for a commercial yeah it was for a
commercial I think it was devour
that sounds about right you know those
oh yeah yeah yeah if anyone's gonna be
this it's like edgy fat guy food devour
they were they were like listen you're
the demo we're going for but we can't
let them know yeah we can't
we can't put you on Front Street
give me like a trailer they look at you
they're like he's gonna buy them no
matter what yeah we gotta get the guy
that ain't gonna buy him
put up a [__] Den up there with
washboard abs eating devour I took a
couple of boxes when I left there are
you gonna lie we want this to be an
aspirational product we want people to
be aspiring to be the spokesperson oh my
God that's [__] good all right uh all
right let's see here this is from Bruce
sounds like Bruce Bruce is it garbage to
buy a grocery store
to buy oh I'm sorry is it garbage to buy
out a grocery store when you find a
price error I got 60 rolls of Jimmy Dean
sausage for a dollar each have you ever
found an error where they're like we got
to give it to you at this price or will
you stock up on anything that's at a
very low price I can't see that I did it
recently you did are you ready for what
happened I hope you're not freezing egg
this is what happened I found I was
trying to eat more protein right so I
found these sausage links you know like
did you write this question no like
jerky okay jerky and it's in a big bag
it was 15 and then I I got it right and
I'm going to check out and I see that
they have these little bags for three
dollars okay and in four bags there was
almost almost twice as many in the big
bag so for 12 bucks you get almost
double what was in there okay and I just
looked at the register the ladies
version I go this is 15. these are I go
how is this working she's like I don't
know and I was just like take the big
bag I'm going minis give me all of them
and I cracked the code and I was just
like you know what's going on here like
you were discussing it with her well I
was making sure that I was an idiot and
then all of a sudden I'm paying like 10
26 you know what I mean so I don't mind
this move did you see that guy that I
don't mind it either that bought the
wheel of cheese you ever see that video
went across like social media this guy
came home and his wife is videoing him
and she's laughing she's like tell
everybody what you did and he's got a
giant wheel of cheese and he's like I
didn't do anything and she's laughing
she's like tell everyone what you did
and he's like all I did was take
advantage of him mispricing because he
bought I mean those wheels of cheese are
like I don't know I'm gonna say between
1200 and [__] 10 grand cheese yeah and I
think someone maybe marked it for like
120. he took on this giant thing of parm
at the grocery store he's he's losing
his mind he's like wait they had that we
had those at the grocery I don't know
wherever he was it was marked down yeah
some Restaurant Depot or something like
that
can't buy that's not for consumers what
are you say you saying this is not
kosher to make this play uh no he's
asking
um uh I think you frowned upon me a
little bit when I told you the move I
think you should tell the assistant
manager there's been a a an error I do
well all right so it's a little
different you were buying a product
already this guy's got 60 rolls of Jimmy
Dean sausage at the house that's like
that means you're eating sausage every
day for for five months he's got the
freezer in the in the garage yeah he's
got the deep freeze out there he's got
the you know pandemic freezer in there
some high school kid got careless with
the uh with the numbers gun yeah I
worked at a grocery store for a long
time and I didn't give a [__] people
would be like yeah so this this coupon
is supposed to be 50 cents cheaper I
gotta take it I don't [__] care I
ain't calling a manager over I ain't
doing nothing I ain't waiting for the
key take it lady you keep bread in the
freezer no never no hot dog buns no okay
I either got him or I don't okay that's
all it is if you can't take a piece of
bread around a hot dog that's
of other bread are you an end man you
know it's a good use of the ends is you
toast them butter them cinnamon sugar on
them for the kids boom boom and they'll
just like it's just like the best way to
go I think you haven't thought of Mr
Larson
got it all covered you know what we do
now is my son loves the pretzel wrapped
hot dog so I just buy those Nathan's
pretzel wrapped hot dog Frozen and then
right boom he loves he think that's why
I wanted I'm going to take him put him
in a microwave you go microwave for a
minute and then five minutes in the
toaster oven you know what I mean look
at you you got a little touches
finishing it off well I mean that's what
they recommend in the Box I can't take
all the credit shout out to Nathan
I think they've done their research I
almost took credit for it I'm like nah I
gotta be straight
fire me up
you know what they have like everywhere
you walk here there's a hot dog staying
with pretzels I'm like I gotta take the
kids here this summer because like
that's like my son's dream like look at
this everything right here I got it he
puts a real you on the hot doesn't it
yeah that's a that's a Massachusetts
thing is it yeah we say rum too rum you
say why do you say roof roof or roof
let's go up on the roof roof okay how do
you say this is a one I should take my
kids up on my mom's roof Second Story
pitch and we'd sit up there and like
stare at the stas
you gotta put that little seed of
Adventure and be like we got it you're
all right let's not be afraid you know
if you fall through if you fall off the
roof you'll survive I mean you might not
you might not but hey you think that
wasn't predetermined before you were
born come on Spade baby okay let's talk
about Express
VPN uh-huh you know what a VPN is who
don't express does it the best and
listen online security these days is a
little risky sure gotta protect yourself
everybody's getting hacked checking your
cookies figuring out where you've been
what are you doing privacy has become a
commodity do yourself a favor
expressvpn is your answer to secure your
online purchases we only recommend
brands that our listeners to our
listeners that we believe in is
something we definitely believe in do
yourself a favor
lock down your online activity with
expressvpn yeah the expressvpn doesn't
log your activity online or make money
by selling your data advertisers uh you
don't need any technical skills to set
it up just fire up the app and tap one
button to connect that's it even your
dumb old grandpa could do it it's uh not
it's not just us saying this seeing that
business inside of the Verge all rated
expressvpn the number one VPN in the
world baby
so check it out go to expressvpn.com
garbage uh we're on the road we use it
all the time you can secure it if I'm
doing banking or whatever I'm on the
road I'm tapped into the wire boom
expressvpn I know I'm getting the best
protection because they get you it's
like having a junkyard dog protecting
you I get hanzi out there head head of
security so protect yourself with the
VPN that we use and Trust use our link
expressvpn.com garbage day to get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package look at that that's
expressvpn.com garbage visit
expressvpn.com garbage to learn more do
it Tom Kippy sent you
um how do you say how do you pronounce
the word the product that Crayola makes
crayons crayons what do you say crowns
oh Jesus Christ this is worse what do
you say crayons
crayons I say crayons crayons that's how
it is yeah yeah but what happened what
happened over there
what kind of abuse went down when you
were a child he fell off the roof that's
what happened I survived they melted in
waxed and he couldn't handle it he just
tumbled yeah Crown I don't know so
Philly people say it that way crown
Crown Crayola crowns wow yeah I love
that I love that everyone there knows
this is not how it said and they're like
[__] it we're gonna do it anyway yeah
it's not even a dialect thing no it's
just like a disregard for the language
putting something in the water down
there
ah all right let's see here uh this is
from Jack ten dollar Bozo never had a
question right is it garbage you use
tongue when you kiss during your wedding
ceremony uh at every VFW wedding I've
ever been to the couples have made out
dirtily
have you ever been to a VFW wedding come
on what do you think no no really no I
wish I had a good time I bet they are a
good time potatoes coleslaw no windows
it's a [__] dude why don't vfws I saw
a deer hunter I know what's up
um I did a benefit in Jersey that was in
a VFW and it was like classy it was like
you know it felt like a rotary club you
know I mean sure little like a little
lamp on each table that's nice yeah I
was like we did stand up there um have I
ever been to a wedding at a vehicle no I
haven't what what do you think the worst
ven you've attended a wedding or you've
watched anything like this is a little
wonky
um
or I mean you do run in nice circles I I
I I mean you know it's like nicest you
know I went out to dinner with a high
school friend last night and we were
talking like you know we grew up in a
middle-class town where nobody was rich
everybody worked hard but like everyone
was like really good kids and like no
one really went astray like we we had a
really good childhood and so uh yeah I
don't know let me think but like most of
my friends like they did it right you
know what I mean they like you know but
I do like the question about like do you
go tongue do you yeah because I don't
think you do the visible tongue you know
what I mean we're like you just go
outside the mouth you do a little slip
yeah you can't be choking her while
you're doing it you know what I mean
because I always because growing up with
no like no parents in the just my mom
you I never saw
I was never given the example of two
people that love each other and that
affection and that yeah kissing is okay
and like you see in like the movies when
the dad is like groping the mom and
she's like yeah what are you doing and
the kid's like you guys are I'm like oh
that's awesome that should be the way it
is you know what I mean so I don't mind
that like you know like I wish that that
was the case so I don't mind a little
tongue in a wedding you know I mean you
[__] do a little more whatever give a
little bit of a shout out of the week
showed up for a reason here there's 200
people here what are we doing I got a
half of drinking
a little bit listen people want to see
love give him love have you guys been to
VFW weddings uh not weddings a lot of
events though I think a lot of like a
lot of our communion parties or
confirmation parties or graduation
parties we're at Knights of Columbus you
know all those kind of yeah clubs we're
still current members of the Elks Lodge
my dad would like ranked oh my God that
was a good one that's a nice one I had
one shitty this one's nice this one's
good we go down the shore we would
always do them down the shore okay yeah
you know for whatever party was
happening always happen to like a night
food's always home run yeah swear to God
I bet he's always a homework company
yeah I did I used to do a fundraiser for
my kids uh preschool every year I did
three years in a row I did a Sam show at
the Elks around the corner shout out we
did a great job Santa Monica Elks yeah
it's like nickel beers oh yeah it's just
guys it feels like you're going back in
time yeah you might get beat up by an
old dude or whatever
that yeah Korean war vet kick your ass
you never did time kind of thing
listen I did 11 days in Iraq
did you go over for that nice how was
that all right yeah it was great I did
go on a helicopter yeah of course that's
the only way you get around you have to
go to give you your own helicopter I
went no five so we went out to like
bases that like we built you know what I
mean like oh yeah yeah and like you
would do a show at one in the afternoon
on rocks and 98 degrees with a mic you
know what I mean in front of dudes
they're just like go ahead you know and
you're like oh geez so I'm sensitive and
take your top off uh
I love a little PDA just on the street
you know what I mean I love when I see a
couple just get down I'm like good for
you guys yeah a little smooch a little
smooch I'll get behind it uh you know
it's pretty when you see like late at
night when you see the couple like pour
out and they're like going to town it's
like midnight and they're just like oh
my God this is inhibition to the win I
have an attic how do you feel about a
little action in the back seat of a cab
or an Uber I have no problem with it
Uber seems a little personal because
there's no like there's no barrier you
know what I mean yeah but uh you know
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
disregard it okay okay all right
I'll never kiss and tell
uh let's see here this is from Devin are
you garbage if you tell people the
dollar amount to the Cent when they ask
how much they owe you for something you
bought for them oh man so if I were to
you know if you were to buy something if
you were to buy something that was let's
call it 18.50 and I go Hey Joe how much
uh hey Jay how much I owe you for that
what what number are you throwing at me
40.
I gotta pay the kids back
you know what this is tough because I've
always been the guy I just was thinking
about this myself I've been picking up
tabs the whole time I've been in New
York anything I'm like I got this
because I don't mind I love being able
to be that guy even if I don't have the
money 100 you know what I mean that's me
and there's a reason why everyone else
has money than me uh-huh so I respect
people when they're not afraid to say oh
let's split this and you oh I do not
like when I go out to eat and someone's
like well I had this and this so I'm
just like we're not playing jump on
mozzarella sticks let's go let's all
just have fun here I would never eat
with those people I that's never
I don't think ever happened to me and I
don't think I would ever eat with those
people again no if that was the case
yeah well and then now we have venmo so
if it's 1850 I'd be like just throw me
18 I would never round I would never say
the 50. okay I would say throw me the
18. now do you send the venmo request
never
I have never sent the venmo request yeah
and it's big with the younger kids
because that's just what they know it's
like hey are you 17 for that how young
you talking like high school kids no new
guy Luke the kid you met yeah he hits me
up immediately out here I mean it is for
businesses yeah but it's like that's
work it's right away I've gone out to
eat that's an invoice I have a tough
time saying invoices I I was a 100p of a
show and I had to send an invoice in
there I'm like can you guys just do this
why am I like I I don't make me ask for
money yeah that's a that's a dirtbag
thing 100 because like money was always
it was either there or it wasn't there
and it was like asking for it yep same
thing my dad would be like I got it I
got it I'd be like we do not have that
we don't got we don't got they just took
the car last week we ain't got it I
don't get I don't understand stand what
an invoice is it doesn't make any sense
you know how much you owe me why why do
you need for tax purposes
but don't that's that's there's no other
reason it's for tax purposes but if you
send it if you sent me 200 and it said
this is for services rendered or
whatever I did what do you mean
let them go here wouldn't that already
be the enough evidence that you paid the
person where's the services rendered
written on the check in the email who's
sending first of all all I'm getting is
I know who's the brains behind this
operation
they're unnecessary I think okay yeah I
mean you need a paper trail yeah you
know what I mean you got to have it all
right well it's like okay I paid Jay ten
thousand dollars and then the government
goes what was that ten thousand dollars
for service is rendered first let's
prove it he's also when you go to a
restaurant you can't just be like what
do we owe you they got to give you a
bill that's what it is it was 88 let's
call it 80.
guys let's say what do I owe you yeah
yeah are you a cash guy I love having
cash the pandemic took that away you
know what I mean like but I I have cash
on me right now you know my talking you
know my I mean not a ton you know what
my favorite bill is though 50 mine's 50.
really the greatest bill of all time I
was thinking that this week it's
classier than the hundred the 50 just
tells people I'm I got something but I
don't need to I don't need to have too
much you know what I mean body come on
yeah I mean I got 55 bucks on me right
now oh man stayed in a nice hotel now
it's a great Hotel it goes from a 50 to
a five that quick well I don't have I
don't carry cash ever anymore you know
what I mean and I'm definitely not a guy
who's carrying like
uh my staple when I was carrying cash
would be like 300 bucks I think 300 get
you out of a jam gets you out of a jam
if you need a bureau you can save the
day if some guy happens to be selling an
armoire on the side of the road that's
nice but he's like I could do it for 300
right now if you take it you know what I
mean so I always liked having a little
cash especially you go you go to
antiques like cash you can yeah you can
knock it down a little bit you know
that's old school East Coast stuff took
yeah yeah a little bit of cash what are
we talking cash price though that's a
big thing growing up my dad would be
like call to see how much those chairs
are I'd be like oh they're 1100 he goes
ask him for cash so I'd be like hey be
like whoa what's the cash price on that
yeah
um by the way someone told me recently
you can haggle at Best Buy no yes you
can haggle at Best Buy like the TV you
can be like no get on that there's no
way you can haggle it best I had friends
do it if it's the floor model oh floor
model always have you ever bought a
floor of course
I love them so there's a little scratch
here the remote's missing the back
whatever whatever I'll do 250. will you
buy a floor mod repairs a floor model
pair of sneakers if the if the ones up
there
I've never been come across that to me
really I have yeah there's like the last
pair in the shop like you know mustard
prints on it or whatever yeah yeah yeah
yeah no that's tough we wear the
sneakers out of the store no really put
them and keep them in the box yep huh
I've never worn them out of the store
I've worn like uh a shirt out of the
store sure you're in a jam yeah jammed
up let me get out of here you know I
mean and you know what I do like to do
when I go like when I went to Austin the
first thing I did I went to a clothing
store that I like and I went and bought
clothes and I'm like I want some new
clothes for this trip you know what I
mean I want to look nice place downtown
yeah I have to get the name of that off
South Congress I'll go over to South
Congress got a new development over
there you go in I go in I shop a little
I go I sit I have a cocktail by myself
then I get back to the hotel look over
my notes really it's a gentleman at the
Garbage Guys
what are you doing pretty clean all
right if you're looking to talk down
price at a Best Buy uh be a dirtbag
you can haggle but only for the open box
stuff or returns okay uh but this says
you can you can do some stuff you can go
with a bundling plan they like if I'm
picking up one of these and one of these
I'll pick up the TV and a VCR
a lot of those are those are for fans uh
you can shop at the end of the month
sometimes they'll knock stuff down when
they're trying to uh quotas or whatever
okay yeah and the price match come in
with a with a you know something from
somewhere else taking matches price
circuit City's doing it for 1100 yeah I
got H4 like doing this for 250.
service is rendered no paper trail with
that guy an invoice yeah could you send
us an invoice for that sorry he doesn't
do invoices we need to prove it sorry
h-fully Industries I mean with no paper
trail with the existence of Photoshop
that's five minutes save 500 you know
what I mean oh yeah
ever a coupon guy
no yeah I can't foresee it I mean every
now and then like you go to Domino's and
you put an order in and then you look at
the price and then you're like oh hold
on a second let me double back because
they have like the like the deals and
you're like all right do we want four
toppings you know you never do you're
cutting open another box getting the
coupon
I wish I I wish I had the patience to
like go I just don't you go grocery
shopping you're like and I gotta go look
for the thing like it's too much I do
have like I shop at different grocery
stores but one I have like a membership
so like if like when you go to buy it'll
be like oh it's 4.99 but if you're a
member it's you know I'll pick those
items sure because I love seeing a
system already yeah yeah I'm sure we've
asked you but where are you going to out
there I go to Vons um that's my staple
because I'm just like a straight up dude
and I like to get the straight up junk
and then every now and then Whole Foods
okay when I first separated I was over
next to a Trader Joe's so we went to
Trader Joe's all the time and we liked
it but now it's just like you know the
the Vons is the way Trader Joe's man
what about the real nice one was it
Raytheon what's it called air one air
one I am just I I
for me I can't understand what would
actually be and most of the food I eat
it and I'm like this just does not taste
causing me that I need a little bit of
[__] or I need some more salt or any
it's just not for me sure it is not for
me and I can't it's like 15 bucks for a
pint of ice cream it's insane yeah it's
just not for me
okay huh all right let's see this one's
from straight trash homie was it garbage
for my dad to make us a basketball net
out of an old milk crate a piece of
plywood and hang it above our carport
every word of that sentence got trashier
and trash here is it when I'll tell you
what that's how Champions are made right
now I'll [__] tell you you know what
the most trash is he said our carport
and you know that's gonna be a shared
car
this gotta be that's a duplex Maybe
[Laughter]
that's the original basketball hoop
isn't it it was a peach uh peach peach
fast basket each basket yeah yeah did
you have a ball uh basketball net
growing up you're running game no no
where'd you go to court you have to go
to the courts or something yeah so
here's the deal like I only organized
Sports I played as a kid was soccer and
baseball played soccer through High
School baseball through college okay
but when we play Hoops like I play with
great friends
you ready for this this is my got a
mouth full of seeds my favorite one I'd
be in right field and I our picture
would throw a strike and I go build a
house there
and then I had a couple kids Billy
Burrell was one of the greatest trash
talkers so like if they were up and they
took a pitch we'd always do this one he
beat one end of The Dugout and he'd be
like can I help you and I'm like not
just looking
for the guy taking a pitch for a strike
were you gum or seeds what did you like
to munch on seeds seeds seeds all day
seeds all just had it packed in over
here and then I went through phases like
I would take one eat it put the shell
over here and stack the shells over here
Jesus and then I was going through like
just straight up eating the whole thing
ah Michelle man myself spitting out yeah
some people go all the way with it
people whoa yeah yeah you were eating
the shells yeah and then you know and
then certain flavors came in later in
the game like Dill barbecue and you're
like all right let's [__] with that
ranch you know the ranch shout out to
David's birthday and they're the only
guy right they're the only guys in the
game these are the ones that come in
like the little sleep Planters is trying
to get in the game yeah
yeah
I was never that good with the with the
back and forth I could only keep like a
little pile right here and then I could
move them down and then spit out the
shell yeah I couldn't have a wad in
there but you'd use that out and eat
them in there in the field too yeah
Jesus well that's what I mean you know
depending you'd spit when you're out in
the field you know it depends on like
what the vibe was sometimes you're just
doing it to pass the time you're like oh
let me just see what I keep over sure
you know do you like the pitch clock by
the way yeah yeah did you see how much
they trim the games down wild like a
half hour there was a game the game game
the other day was two hours and 10
minutes that is insane man so I don't
mind because there's nothing I'm gonna
do to change it think about all the
clock chirps you would have too going on
if there was a clock cooking back then
oh my God you would just be like keep it
moving too yeah dude the best in college
we played against assumption and these
kids had a couch out in right field
behind the fence and they're sitting on
the couch drinking time and I'm out
there and they'd be like 18 18. what
inning is it man and I look over I'm
like we're in the seventh and they're
like all right and then they just keep
asking me questions and it was like
spring weekend and then one of them goes
uh hey let's go back to that party I can
just hear the whole because let's go
back to that part and he's like nah stay
and watch the game and he goes let's
buck up for it he goes you know I've
never lost a buck up you want to Buck up
against me right now I've never lost a
buck up and he's like I'll buck up it
went the whole inning debating the buck
up to see who they if they were gonna go
back to that bar that's a buck up like
twos and ones or rock paper scissors
okay yeah I got you I gotcha you [__] up
we call them two you know you go twos
and ones odds and evens right yeah yeah
yeah yeah never heard that buck up I
thought that would land a little better
I was more confused to [__] up
um all right let's see here we got time
for a couple of more here gang uh let's
see this is from coochie Mane is it
garbage you have color flood lights on
the house outside of your house my
parents growing up decided a red
floodlight was the best option that's
you're gonna they talk about yet the
community board yeah that's rough with
the red house red what are we doing
that's weird Halloween Christmas I'll
give you
you know Lithuania is in trouble you
want to go with yellow and blue sure
sure go for it if you guys think you're
the top of the Empire State Building all
right whatever
um no you think it's considered you
gotta go stand there straight white yeah
straight white when's that Christmas
tree come down at your house it came
down pretty soon after Christmas this
year goes up pretty early though really
I like December 1st that's uh
come on enjoy it it's down before the
new year for sure okay I mean it might
be nice New Year's Day is a good day I
would think to take it down sure you
know that's pretty good December 1st
perspective I will be honest though if
I'm gonna make a confession the lights
outside the house are still up at my
place just because I'm lazy right now I
just don't want to get out there and get
them dead today April you know the
people in the neighborhood well I just
got the lawn blown out I'll take them
down this weekend I'll get them down
this weekend come on every once in a
while huh no you have them up why not
still got extension cords and [__] in
the front yard Jay yeah I got the
Charlie Brown lights you know what I
mean it's not like white people wait you
got the Big Bolt you got big color bulbs
yeah hanging in April
there's a little bit of trash in all of
us and I admitted it I could have not
told you guys that I could have held on
to that foreign
too busy making bouquets on [__]
weekend that's what I'm saying yeah cool
yeah
get some work done close the shop we're
trying to make a profit here have Lewis
I got invoices to get out
well what's the point you're where's the
break-off point where you just cycle
yeah if you don't get them down by June
I would say there is one neighbor across
the street and I know he's a little
annoyed by it I can tell why what [__]
him he had his up for a while too and
then like I was like ah well now you're
making him look good though yeah and
everyone else had him now I got now I
did the long clean out and the whole
house is looking great so I'm like all
right let me I'll get him down you know
he's getting the mail bumping into
people like Larson's still got the
lights off Larson still got him up I got
mine down
anybody in anybody in the neighborhood
that don't really quite take care of
their property that that you you
everyone's got that old person in the
neighborhood whose house is still
running the muck they gotta ramp up to
the front door you know what I mean
they're they're looking High Grass and
[__] yeah yeah that's going on at my
ex's hand at mine but yeah we got a
couple of those in the neighborhood no I
don't care I'm just like whatever it's
not like a you know what I mean drags
down a property value for everybody
not in L.A the property valve is doing
Justice
doing just fine he will survive uh all
right let's see this one's from Ian ever
see one of your bones
no
have you yeah I have you oh yeah which
one my knee my leg
man that's the trashiest question I know
ever see one of your bones well that's
not even I mean that's just like I mean
I saw my boy Jake's when we were playing
let me slid into second and popped it
and knew right away compound fracture
yeah just boom gone tibia uh no femur
fibio between the [__] the shin the shin
that whole thing I think that's referred
to in the medical practice as the shin
bone yeah shin bone
um but no I've never broken anything
I've ruptured the Achilles Last year you
know what I mean so I was doing that for
five months but uh never dunk again
that hurt real bad when it happened that
hasn't hurt at all no when it no doesn't
hurt at all I didn't tear it I just
ruptured it which it means if I like
ripped half of it the whole thing didn't
rip but half of it ripped it like popped
like a strings of a guitar did it go up
did it go back up I don't know what
happened but it didn't hurt at all oh
that's cool it just is like you can't
walk and you yeah you know and then you
gotta immediately go get it taken care
of yeah what uh what was the ridge you
have a boot on that yeah oh boots Castle
then boot no surgery no surgery okay you
know what if you think I [__] held
back I went out and bought a Vespa the
next day so I could get the kids around
we cruise around three of us on a Vespa
with a little Vietnamese families I had
sitting on the crutches the three of us
backpacks to school booed out people
like can you do this I'm like I'm doing
it I'm doing it baby you see us we're
killing it damn
get my son to the skate park four miles
away side streets oh that's sick dude
those kids must have thought you shred
they love dude they love that scooter
every time I'm like we'll take it home
from I pick him up from school in the
scooter and they're like see my dad on
the scoot they love it I hit the horn
going through a toll booth
I don't have it can you break a 50.
gang Mr Jay Larson brand new special
about right now on his YouTube page Jay
Larson comedy sounds like Bruce
unbelievable I can do this all day with
you guys thank you buddy thanks for
having me said open invite anytime
you're in New York I love it I love you
guys we love you brother anything else
you want the folks out there to know no
that's it just go watch it share it rate
review uh send to friends like anything
you can do to get the word out there I
love this [__] community and I hope
you guys enjoy the special and I
appreciate you guys having me on one of
the coolest things the fans are doing is
they're jumping in the uh the comments
yeah
pretty YG sent me a shout out so get in
there let them know the [__] Army of
garbage is out there in full effect baby
we love you again Kippy what do you got
for him uh guys we're all over the road
we're adding more dates get your tickets
now shows are selling out [__] thank
you so much we love yous we'll see you
next week please